[Music]  don't wake up let's go the elephant's  Nino's look at that baby  we got a baby what is that a face only a  mother could love  sir many of us find you handsome I was  talking about the elephant you have  until tomorrow night to fix that me make  those ears disappear don't look at me hi  baby jumbo welcome to the circus brought  them here no matter how small  yes something very rare  [Music]  you have wonder  [Music]  you have matter come with me  [Music]  together we should saw all that other  things wings  [Music]  your miracle I wasn't Dumbo  okay big deep this is it just like in  rehearsal except the lights music firing  crowds you couldn't do it  quite alone fly  [Music]